all right so you guys are obviously very
close with each other uh in this movie
what did you do to form that bond
together to play father and daughter
what did we do baby
[Music]
i don't know it takes me a while to warm
up to people i will say but uh
and when i do
i i just start making fun of them
and i start dogging them and just just
completely roasting them so
i don't know when it started but you
must have done something to make me feel
comfortable enough to roast you she was
definitely it was it was interesting i'm
not actually going to post all of the
our first day moments like when this
movie comes i'm going to post everything
and then all of our little fun moments
lisa
oh you've got the oh look at us
oh my god pluto look at this picture
look at this picture of us that's cute
at least
you are so tiny oh my goodness
calm my face with your with your hands
she was really cute she was definitely
i was like i was nervous because i'm
like i
chose her i got i i've got to be like
come on mama your dad
are you putting socks on right now i am
he's a sad guy
i'm not normally a sock guy but i put
socks on right now
keep those feet warm you know these
junkets are chilly
so you were nervous because you chose
her well right you're producing in this
one right you put your boss yeah yeah my
best friend's directing it so it's just
kind of like i i felt very
nervous because i was like you know so i
chose what i wanted and like when i met
her she was definitely staying obviously
quiet and i was like oh you know i'm
very gregarious and big and loud and i
can scare people off so
good thanks she did hear you
no he didn't scare me i just i just like
don't know how i
can approach people when i don't know
their sense of humor or like how they
are or like what how much is too much so
if anything i was scared of scaring you
did she scare you
she made me nervous
there's nowhere to hide we know who you
are
people are gonna come after us aren't
they i need to go well there's one scene
where you you physically fight this man
you beat up on him what is it like to
say you fought aquaman
i'm just really really happy that i can
leave this earth maybe go to another
planet when i die knowing that i got to
pull that man bun
yee i yanked it
she yanked it
no one's yanked the man bun only
isabella
he's looking with some pride in his eyes
right now you were proud of her fighting
i'm extremely proud of her fighting
skills man
well jason you are playing a very
protective papa in this movie obviously
how much does your own real-life papa
bear mentality inform a role when you
come into something like this
i
mean well it's kind of like why i chose
the the piece there's a
i've never got to play a father
with a teenager
with a young teen and an older you know
older team and uh
i lola wasn't quite that age yet but now
she is and so i'm kind of coming in too
oh how you doing
i'm all right but i'm going to need
isabella's help where i'm like hey
remember when i taught you all those
stunts and like i hired you now your big
action star i could use some of your
help
i feel like
wifey's gonna need help too because
there's always gotta be a bad guy
and i feel like you
are like the she's probably a daddy's
girl you're probably the good guy huh
probably
wrong i'm really but i'm really hard i'm
really i'm way harder than my wife is
though
really that does surprise me i'm super
strict that's weird
that's very surprising because you're
very chill i'm very very
yeah i'm wired
are we are we grounding them what are
the punishments you're
doling out
well
i mean i just take everything i mean
okay yeah don't leave them don't even
leave them with the with with any wi-fi
if i mother i would be grounding all the
time
but your kids do have i mean speaking of
you and your lovely wife some incredible
acting jeans could you put them in one
of your movies one day would you say
man one of them wants to do it and i'm
not a fan and i don't want
them too but uh
i don't know i'll try with my i'll try
my damn just to keep him out of it
really but you don't you love it
i love storytelling i love back to
filmmaking so i mean i like you know
directing and filmmaking but um i just
i want them to you know go for other
things if they want to maybe
but i i don't want them to get into
acting it's very hard
very hard it's very hard on people and
uh
you know i don't want them to have that
kind of pressure
there's a lot of like extra stuff that
comes with acting that you're like i
didn't sign up for this but you love it
so you got to do it
yeah and it's like
i'm tough enough to handle it but i
wouldn't want to put someone i love
into it
well it sounds like you might be doing
more producing and directing one day do
you want to head in that direction yeah
well i've been directed for a while now
so it's been uh it's been a passion that
you know i'd rather see the full project
than just being the one piece of it but
it's nice also just being the actor so
i'm happy i have to be both
by the way jason small world but my last
interview right before this was yaya for
his new movie candy man
it's a small world but i'm literally
interviewing jason right after this do
you have any message for him i can say
oh no just tell him i said what's up
just tell him
and i'll see him next week that's this
this
i'll tell him you didn't say
anything um
love him love him also he said to tell
you that he did not spoil anything but
you know what can you tell me about the
aquaman sequel i ain't saying none i'm
gonna get in trouble on that one
you